hello and uh thank you to lab roots for
inviting me for this webinar today my
name is caleb king i'm the director
of process development at front range
biosciences
um front range is today i want to bring
a little bit about front range to you
and then also
how we use at front range the
metabolomics based breeding approach
specifically metabolomics-based breeding
for cannabis varieties
i'm able to share a lot of these
insights to you today about
metabolomics-based breeding largely
thanks to
to the incredible research development
team that i'm part of at front range
many members of my team have been
tremendous contributions to the field of
cannabis science over the last
decade with their experiences ranging
from agronomy
to pharmacognosy frontrange in
particular is a biotechnology company
that has specialized in tissue culture
propagation of high-value crops such as
hemp and coffee this year our company is
expanding its portfolio
with distribute distribution of hemp
seeds throughout north america
and just last week front range
biosciences sent the very first plant
cell cultures
into space to go to the international
space station
and study microgravity effects on plant
cell cultures
which will provide a future
understanding and developing new
varieties for the industry as a whole
organisms that have experienced zero
gravity environments in the past have
taught us a lot
about metabolic changes under these
unique conditions
so we're very excited for this data and
this research to come to fruition
by the end of this webinar today i hope
to familiarize listeners
with the analytical and statistical
techniques employed in the field of
metabolomics
we also will explore how the cannabis
industry can avoid some of the pitfalls
of other agricultural commodities
that have been around for a while as a
result of breeding
by just a handful of agronomic studies
or ergonomic traits as a whole
for example just using yield alone to
breed for a crop now i want to clarify
that i'm not trying to minimize
selective breeding based on phenotypic
traits
but instead state the importance of
combining all of these breeding
techniques
to make this plant's breeding process
more efficient
to begin i think it's critical to have a
basic understanding of metabolomics and
how it relates to
other omits based approaches um in
biological organisms
as illustrated here you have a slide
where you have metabolomics next to
genomics
transcriptomics proteomics metabolomics
in and of itself
is the study of small molecules
specifically let's use examples here
such as lipids
carbohydrates and amino acids
it's often helpful to think of
metabolomics as a form of archaeology or
paleobotany paleobotany is the study of
what organisms in geologic time
have laid down clues for us in the rock
record
now plants and some of their chemical
signatures have been preserved
in the rocks but it's only specific
tissue types that are able to be
mineralized and have that resistance to
digest
or the long-term decomposition of
organic matter
which often depends on the environmental
conditions surrounding these plants at
the time
and at the point in history when they're
laid down plant metabolomics is
no different in this respect because
it's the study of what small molecules
have been produced by the plant the
chemical signatures may be different
from the original compound due to
environmental conditions such as light
vapor pressure presence of enzymes in
the atmosphere
a bunch of other variables that could be
involved to alter these small molecules
and it makes metabolomics a really fun
puzzle sometimes but also very
challenging
so the only major difference between
paleobotany and metabolomics
is the time scale upon which these
changes occur we're talking millions of
years
or it's a matter of seconds if you can
identify these chemical degradations or
even yet better yet
model them you can begin to relate
changes in these small molecule types
to concentrations and what is known
about the biochemical pathways occurring
in a plant
under optimal environmental conditions
and under
conditions such as biotic or abiotic
stressors
so what's impacting this phenotype from
the environment
if you can identify these as well you
have a greater
ability to predict how this plant will
respond to
future biotic stresses so this is where
other olmics approaches
become valuable to our understanding
because genomics can help us predict the
phenotype
that will be observed while
transcriptomics and proteomics tell us
what is occurring in the plant at the
present moment
or what's being transcribed from the dna
to the rna to proteins to enzymes
so if changes occur in the phenotype as
a result of environmental stressors
it's often an indicator that the
metabolomic pathway has also changed
usually in the measurable form of dna
rna
proteins or metabolites hence why you
see here
the dotted line connections going from
the phenotypic responses to abiotic and
biotic stresses
back to the top of the system's
biological paradigm
i think also it's important to see
here that we have a metabolic map for
every single organism and that's what's
displayed here in this slide
this map was constructed for arabidopsis
using omix-based approaches
the colors on the map represent
different metabolic pathways
such as lipids carbohydrates amino acids
i'm sure you can guess all of these
pathways are connected one another
at multiple points and knowing these
major connections
and the metabolites involved in each
connection is incredibly useful for
predicting downstream effects
simply say think of this map as a map of
a state
where the major thoroughfares are
depicted but you probably couldn't use
this map
to navigate your way around a major
metropolitan city
that's to say this map has its limits in
its resolution
fortunately we know a little bit about
the minor streets and alleys of each
metabolic pathway implants
and that's what's depicted here in this
blown-up picture of the terpene
biosynthesis
don't forget understanding this pathway
in front of you it's not it's not
necessarily important to understand that
pathway in front of you
but it's important to notice that the
squares containing the numbers in the
pathway
and these green squares represent
enzymes more specifically
their genetic code that's involved to
make these enzymes operate
and reproduce construction of
biochemical pathways and their
intermediates their enzymes involved
their cofactors
is absolutely paramount to understanding
how plants will respond
to biotic and abiotic stressors
which will look a little something like
this in this next slide
and this next slide was a metabolic map
constructed
again using arabidopsis
where you have a diagram of the enzymes
and their transcription factors they
have genes involved
the biotic or the abiotic pathways
this kind of map is incredibly complex
and it's likely
not to be complete so you know
nonetheless
it still is valuable for its
understanding of biotic and abiotic
stressors
but there's a lot more to this that you
can't see and we don't fully understand
it so knowing these biotic and abiotic
pressures that that cause these pathways
to
be what they are we can understand these
cascades
and these cascades are similar between
different plant families
as an example arabidopsis doesn't
produce cannabinoids that we know of
but it still utilizes same as some of
the same chemical pathways as cannabis
to respond to fungal stresses which we
know that fungal stress is
most certainly minimize cannabinoid
production in cannabis
because the plant the cannabis plant is
essentially placing all of its resources
to fighting off a fungal attack or a
pathogen
there's still a lot we need to
understand about the interaction of
these biochemical pathways and the
changes they undergo
when placed under different
environmental stressors
so how do we measure these pathways and
their intermediates their products
their degradation products how do we
measure all of that
well you use instrumentation such as gas
chromatography
liquid chromatography capillary
electrophoresis
coupled to mass spectrometers as well as
nuclear magnetic resonance um
i'll break down here what each of these
instruments do but
it's important to realize that these
high resolution
mass spectrometers and also high
sensitivity mass spectrometers
are able to really tell you fine details
between different
molecules and that becomes incredibly
important in the biochemical pathways
and understanding these
biochemical pathways so
gcms specializes in small molecules by
being able to detect and quantify
volatile compounds such as hydrocarbons
esters ketones
aldehydes lipids some amino acids
so basically smaller molecules lcms
is generally capable of quantifying
medium to larger molecules
and can measure sugars polyphenols
lipids lipids such as cannabinoids
cems is excellent for the separation of
molecules by charge
and also requires less solvent than the
lcms so it's great and environmentally
friendly in that regard
its best capabilities are for ionic
compounds such as nutrients and amino
acids
you may be familiar with other similar
techniques
in the ce category such as ion exchange
chromatography
which is similar in application and
function
lastly you see we have nmr nuclear
magnetic resonance
which is an excellent instrument for
structural elucidation of compounds
and for isotopic labeling studies
we're going to touch on this a little
bit later in this talk where we
discuss metabolic fluxes and you have to
use heavy isotopes
or isotopes that are laden with more
neutrons to
be able to label two molecules and
measure where those
those biochemical pathways are being
traced throughout the system so they act
as great tracers isotopes hectares great
tracers
for metabolic flux experiments
the data generated from each of these
instruments is
often used um but
it's only as useful as the extraction
and sample cleanup methodologies that
are implemented
which unfortunately are often
oversimplified and results in skewed
results sometimes so it's important to
understand that the matrix that you're
using
and how best to extract the chemical
components of that matrix of interest
which requires drawing on previous
studies previous published studies
preferably
databases that exist out there such as
the nist database for mass spectra
or by validating methods and assessing
their technical limits
so going through the full validation
protocol measuring accuracy precision
robustness uncertainty
um if the data is to be valid
um one has the potential then to reverse
engineer an underlying metabolic pathway
by utilizing statistical techniques such
as these shown here
which is on the left you have
hierarchical clustering and on the right
you have
principal components analyses there's
many others i haven't shown here
but these are some examples of
statistical analyses
that can help you show inferences about
what's going on the metabolic pathway
there is a ton of data being generated
from these instruments
and collecting that and merging it all
together to make sense of what's going
on in the biological pathway
is is difficult um but these tools
really make it possible to do that
so to summarize the purpose to this
slide is to show you how to obtain the
data of interest about a metabolic
pathway
and how to condense large amounts of
data to make meaningful interpretations
that can be useful then for breeding
um let's move on here to um
a somewhat similar family or if you go
up
the the family tree to the tomato family
and
um i want to discuss this before we get
into cannabis-based metabolomics
breeding
because it provides evidence of where
metabolomics-based breeding has provided
a wealth of knowledge for other
agricultural commodities
in the past and the story of the tomato
is
is really fascinating in terms of
metabolomics
and the data that tells the story is
equally as valuable
i think especially for cannabis going
forward
so let's review the evolution of the
domesticated tomato
and i hope to show you where
metabolomics-based breeding helped
revive this crop
and the graph above here is the genetic
diversity
represented by a biological index here
of h
this is of tomatoes grown in europe
between 1960 and present
the graph also extrapolated a little bit
before 1960
some of the vintage varieties and they
what they did to obtain some of that
data is going back to biobanks that
existed this graphic is really excellent
because it simply shows how the tomato
is a great example of an
agricultural commodity that has
experienced genetic erosion over time
where the loss of genetic diversity
through domestication
as a result of phenotypic selective
breeding alone we didn't have a lot of
these instrumentations and techniques
prior to 1960.
notice how the genetic diversity in
tomato populations decreased until the
1960s but started to increase
afterwards this increase in genetic
diversity also so happens to coincide
with a decrease in resistance of the
tomato
to biotic stresses such as insects and
pathogens
the widespread use at the time of hard
harmful insecticides and herbicides
and fungicides as well was very
prevalent in the 1960s and even before
so they could still meet consumer demand
for tomatoes
other agricultural commodities have
experienced similar issues in the last
century and this includes
bananas maize wheat peas
barley and a whole list of others
fortunately scientists realized around
the 1970s
for the tomato that the genetic
diversity of this fruit
was important and so they took the
tomato as a model organism
where research efforts were dedicated to
our agricultural breeding
based on color based on smell and
resistance to biotic stressors
as well as the typical phenotypic traits
such as yield and size
the breeding efforts introduced genetic
diversity into the population
by using heirloom and landrace varieties
at the time so that's how they began to
pick genetic diversity back up again was
grabbing outside populations
and breeding them in
the increase in genetic diversity since
the 1970s can also be observed
in agronomic parameters such as the
fruit's mass
the circle sizes in this first graph
correspond to the size of the tomato
variety introduced at the time
the graph illustrates an increase in the
mass of tomatoes where the water content
the juiciness of a tomato
as well as the overall dimensions and
commercially sold tomatoes around the
1980s
continuing all the way to the press
notice in figure 1 how smaller tomato
varieties appeared in the
late 1980s this represents the
introduction of the cherry tomato
into breeding germplasms at the time
the second figure here investigates
tomato diversity at a primary metabolite
level
or metabolites that are critical for the
function of the plant
i think the citric acid cycle for sugars
think uh the shakimate pathway pathway
for amino acid production
and again you have the introduction of
the cherry tomato
which is mostly sweetened taste in the
late 1980s
as evident in this figure where the
total sugar content in the varieties
went
up while the acidity or the bitter
polyphenols went down
this third figure here takes the genetic
diversity one step further
by examining secondary metabolites
specifically volatile organic carbons
now these compounds aren't considered
very important or essential necessarily
for the plant's function
although they might have purposes such
as insect resistance
but they do have a critical role in the
taste and the smell of many tomato
varieties
these metabolites also serve as
biomarkers for future breeding of tomato
varieties
it's extremely easy to see by this graph
that tomato breeding resulted not only
in phenotypic differences
but changes in the primary and secondary
metabolites as well
beginning from the 1980s and going on
let's transition to canvas where the
verdict of
total genetic diversity still isn't out
yet but
there's some clues about what might be
going on in the population at least here
in north america as dispensaries in
states that legalize cannabis
this graph is a timeline average of thc
weight percent
of cannabis flower confiscated by law
enforcement officials between 1995
and 2014. um very clearly you can see
that the potency of cannabis has gone up
over time
the vast majority of cannabis is
increasing in thc content which is to
say that higher potent sea flower
varieties
are being bred which gets me thinking
what effects does that have on cannabis
on an agricultural scale
what effects does that have on the
population canvas if that's what
breeders and consumers are ultimately
wanting
we have to be thinking about our
breeding effects because cannabis is
moving to an agricultural commodity
especially hemp right now with the
development of new regulations
worldwide
in continuation this graph on the left
is the ratio of thc as cbd between 1995
and 2014 in which you see the decrease
in cbd concentrations of confiscated
samples
and an increase in the thc
concentrations over time
biologically speaking what's happening
here is that an enzyme responsible
converting
cbg or the primary cannabinoid down into
cbda or thca specifically the cbda
enzyme is being turned off and
it's not being inherited or it's
possibly not being inherited
by the population's gmo genome
to be fair this graph probably looks
different today as a result of
regulations for the hemp industry
which included the addition of cbd um
this occurred in 2014
and then again in 2018.
second you have the resurgence of cbd
varieties to meet the consumer demand
which has really taken off in the last
two years as you can evidence by all the
cbd products on shelves
and then third you have breeding from
mixed ratio varieties or varieties with
a balanced amount of thc or cbd
along with varieties containing a
greater quantity of other minor
cannabinoids that you might not be
familiar with
such as cbc cbg the
barons so i anticipate this trend to
change especially in the coming years
and it'll be great to see
somebody redo this study on a global
scale
the graph here on the far right then is
also a clue to what's going on in
cannabis varieties in north america
and it indicates that varieties may be
genetically static
i say maybe there this makes them
vulnerable to biotic or abiotic
pressures
in this figure you have the y-axis as
heterozygosity
which is the population for hemp and
drug-type cannabis samples
collected the heterozygosity is really
just the measurement of genetic
adversity
ranging from zero to one within a group
of individuals
and this study in particular utilized
over 14 000
single nucleotide polymorphisms snips as
you might
have referred to them as a genetically
distinct regions of a plant's dna
which assess then the heterozygosity or
the difference between different
strains different varieties that are
presented
um some new studies may contradict this
hypothesis here that we have
low heterozygosity in the population
and that that there may be
actually distinct regions or populations
of cannabis that have a high
heterozygosity but they're just limited
geographically
determining genetic diversity requires
extensive sampling of hemp and the drug
type cannabis populations across the
world
with consistent sequencing to fully
access the standing biogeographic
diversity
and how the diversity has changed over
time i have not seen the scale of work
done yet
but i'm looking forward to that in
future
one thing that we should learn from
agri-agricultural commodities that have
come before canvas
such as the tomato that i presented in
the slide back is that breeding via
a single phenotypic trait is
really elementary breeding it has
consequences
and makes these plants more susceptible
to biotic and abiotic stressors
the cannabis industry must move away
from cbd
and thc based breeding and just
concentrations alone
or any single cannabinoid for that
matter if we want to breed this plant
like other modern agricultural crops
happen
so what else metabolically is going on
in the cannabis plant that can really be
tapped into and utilized
for metabolomics-based breeding
approaches
let's go through this um the plant here
the cannabis plant from the top to the
bottom
or the above ground biomass to the below
ground biomass
the first chart here is a delineation of
over 175
distinct compounds in the cbd dominant
cannabis flower
or the tissue locate the tissue that's
responsible for the majority of
terpenoid and cannabinoid production you
can see far and away here from this
graph that the turbinoids make up the
majority of trichome chemical components
but not all and you see you have
cannabinoids other lipids you have
flavonoids and organic acids this is
again just for one variety of cannabis
this is just for a cbd dominant variety
we still don't understand how this graph
could possibly change for
different varieties out there like high
thc or a fiber-based variety
the second chart here explores the
stocks of cannabis specifically
in this example the bass fibers and the
pulp that are often used for industrial
hem
in the red square here you see that hemp
stems are primarily composed of
hemicellulose they have a small amount
of lignin
and are predominantly cellulose but that
doesn't account for 100
of the stocks weight or its dry weight
which means that there are secondary
metabolites which is shown in the second
graph over
uh secondary metabolites such as sterols
and then this third graph down below
here
try terpenoids and continuing on this
third graph explores the secondary
metabolites in the roots as well
which is primarily composed again of
structural compounds such as lignin and
cellulose
but there's also a very strong source in
there of secondary compounds such as
tri-terpinoids
and in particular one tritarpinoid
that's been observed to be very dominant
in cannabis plant
is friedelman if you have the
opportunity to harvest a cannabis root
and take a smell of it maybe smell its
neighbor's root and a few other
varieties roots
i strongly encourage that you will
definitely tell the differences
between these roots and their secondary
compounds
we know that a lot of other plants out
there produce a lot of
other metabolites below ground and that
influences them the above ground biomass
there's there's definitely a connection
here between the two that just hasn't
been
um ascertained yet for this plant so
there's a great wealth of opportunity
there
um this next graph here then
goes through the basically
what's connected to each other in the
plant so in nature it's typical to think
um
for a lot of us i should say i tend to
think of things
and i struggle to go beyond this is
think of variables in one dimension
that is to say you look for cause and
effect of variables
or one metabolite but it turns out that
many of these secondary metabolites are
linked to one another as illustrated in
this matrix correlation plot
these correlation matrices assist in
identifying terpene synthase is
responsible
for promiscuous terpenes in the plant
what might be going on further up in the
biochemical chain
so if you know that something's
connected that can be very useful for
you
this figure in particular has heavy dots
representing a positive correlation
between two terpenes
and the red dots represent a negative
correlation between two terms
let's explore more in particular here
the beta caryophyllene
and humaline correlation that are
highlighted here in red
to understand a little bit more about
the alpha humaline and
beta-caryophyllene synthesis
it's important to go through
sesquiterpene biosynthesis as a whole
which starts really with sugars in the
systole of
some of these cells in the plant that
then condense
down into acetyl coas or these primary
metabolites
that go through the mebolonic pathway
and have an inner couple intermediates
along the way
represented here and you have the red
arrows as you go as enzymatic pathways
involved where enzymes that are
making those reactions occur so you go
from acetyl-coa to
the dmapp as for short
then you have gpp which gpp is also a
precursor for cannabinoids and
monoterpenes
so there's some diversion of that
pathway and then within
the plastid of an organism of a plant
organism
you have fpp being produced and that fpp
is transferred into alpha-humaline and
beta-carotene by the exact same enzyme
involved
and we know this because the slide here
or the on the graph on the right
shows the concentrations of
alpha-humaline and beta-caryophyllene
linked to one another
this holds true not only for cannabis
for hops as well
where you have the concentrations of
beta-carotene to humaline
at a ratio of about three to one so
there's certainly the same enzyme
producing these two
it's the energetic favorability of
producing that ratio so what's going on
here we're able to see that
um so if you're trying to breed a plant
that's higher in beta-carotelline for
let's say you want it for sedative
effects or for protective effects of the
plant
beta-carotelline is known to be a very
good nematode inhibitor at least in
roots of corn
you're aware that some of these terpene
compounds may as
may be useful for biomarkers and you'll
have other chirpings that come along for
the ride
because gene expression of terpenes is
linked to metabolite production
a breeder could also monitor one terpene
analyte or use
gene expression techniques to monitor a
terpene terpene synthase expression in
particular
and all this is important because then
you can identify abiotic or
biotic stressors to a plant and make
adjustments to the environment by
either adding trace nutrients watering
more or less having different uv
exposure
changing the genetics entirely
also it helps you breed for the specific
flavors and smells
that typically have medicinal effects
for cannabis
and you have other metabolites in there
that you can do this for as well this
doesn't just apply
to these two terpenes there's a list of
other compounds out there
that have the same enzyme involved in
producing a result
metabolite so understanding and breeding
for specific terpene profiles will
require a really good understanding of
the gene family involved
and this is going to hold true again for
other secondary metabolites in the
cannabis plant of medicinal interest
so let's move on from looking at a
serpent certain
or a single terpene class and looking
for what's involved in making up the
entire biosynthetic pathway
let's move all the way up to the primary
metabolites such as sugars and amino
acids
it's important to understand how much
energy is involved in this terpene
pathway
because or any matter that any pathway
for that matter
because there's really no outputs unless
there's inputs
and transcriptomics gives us a great
clue of where these inputs are coming
from
and what needs to be measured and that's
what i've shown on this slide
the picture on the left you have a great
beautiful picture of
a microscopic image a fluorescent
microscope image
of a cannabis capitated trichome where
the fluorescent dyes in this image
illustrate the flow of certain molecules
between the trichome bulbs
and the mesothelial cells of the leaf
tissue below
what i want you to notice here is that
the glandular heads of the trichomes
and in particular the white secretory
cells at the base of the trichomes
are releasing what look like air bubbles
in the middle of the trichome
and these air bubbles are basically
lipid vesicles being released
and the lipids are expensive to make
they're extremely expensive to make for
excel
that's not just for plants that's for
any organism
there's a lot of energy that's involved
we have a lot of enzymes atp
amino acids carbohydrates photons
etc that go into making these lipid
molecules for the plant
and we know that cannabis makes a lot of
them so it's not cheap to make this
metabolite
and that can be illustrated here with
this diagram on the right
it's a little more complex but
essentially is an expression diagram
for cannabis trichome at the height of
flowering and it's broken down into
regions of cell activity
what i want you to notice about these
different regions are the red and blue
squares that make up those regions
red means that there's a higher gene
expression going on in the plant
blue means there's a lower gene
expression or a down regulation of a
gene
so you can see that the secretory cells
of the trichome are working overtime to
produce not just the cannabinoids and
the terpenes
that's represented by the the lipid
square here
but also other building blocks such as
amino acids
you have other cells meant for cell wall
maintenance that are being upregulated
and not only that but there's so much
energy to demand in these trichomes
that fermentation is also being
activated so
you see these pop-up regions where
there's a lot of activity going on
and these maps are vital for our
understanding of how the plant works
because knowing when biogeochemical
processes
ramp up in the flowering cycle or when
peak gene expression occurs
gives you a thorough understanding and
allows other transcriptomic
processes or other omics based
approaches to come in
and create metabolic flux models for
this plant
how much is it capable of producing when
i say a flux what's the in what's the
out
how much is involved how much energy is
involved with that
and it really gives us the true
capabilities or the limitations of this
plant
and this applies not only to cannabinoid
production but all secondary
compounds produced in the cannabis that
i went through a few slides back
a flex model looks something like this
illustration here
that was done by a group of researchers
for peppermint
which the authors looked at terpene
production and the glandular trichomes
of peppermint species
what they did is they used isotope
labeling techniques which as i mentioned
earlier
in this talk using stable or
radioisotope tracers
and then measuring those heavier
isotopes with
an nmr or mass spectrometer a special
mass spectrometer is going to be useful
and measuring where these tracers end up
in the plant
asses gives you access to what secondary
metabolism is going on and how much of
that metabolism is going on
combining their work with others the
authors were able to model the output
of different terpenes in this plant and
other polyphenols from these individual
or trichomes
trichomes these small scale models can
then be scaled up to the whole plant
and give you experimentally give you the
density and coverage on the plant
and how much energy is involved
throughout the entire plant as a whole
these scaled up estimates really give
breeders a quantitative guidance
and so we know whether genetics is worth
keeping or whether it's worth breeding
going forward with
or we know that it's kind of reached its
max capacity
flux models are also useful for knowing
the limits of a genetically engineering
a plant
which has become a hot topic these days
and you have to know what that plant's
really producing
really has capability to produce for
everything has a limit and that's what
flux models really tell you is where is
that upper limit
and that lower limit for a plan
let's wrap up our discussion today by
reviewing the steps involved to
successfully implement a
metabolomics-based breeding approach
and so to begin you obviously need to
identify what improvement needs to occur
in the plant
is there an abiotic stress is there a
biotic stress that's involved
that's causing problems with the
breeding project so identify
what needs to be improved upon
the second you need to find out out
there what in the research or what in
the literature has already happened for
this plant
again that's going to comply to anything
for cannabis not just cannabis alone
but assessing the metabolic pathways and
the genetic markers that others have
utilized in
other plant species that may be similar
such as hops or
use in general what what has already
been done for cannabis out there there's
a few great researchers
that have published some markers for
cannabis breeding
the third step then is to have an
experimental design
and the experimental design is to assess
the biotic or the aviotic pressures
that you need to improve upon so you
really got to assess those in this step
and this requires evaluating all the
metabolic pathways involved
that are of interest and minimizing the
variables that are
not related to that pathway of interest
so cutting out all the variables and
simplifying the experiment
to find out what the effect is
the fourth step then is collecting the
data from these experiments
and what's involved here is again the
extraction methodologies and the
instrumentation that are utilized
that has to be critically determined
here and can't be overlooked
the fifth step then is data
interpretation
this data interpretation can include
flux modeling and statistical analyses
clustering analyses so how is the data
grouping
what does that tell you about the
biochemical pathway and what enzymes
might be involved to do the exact same
metabolic process that you're interested
in
taking that data then one to the next
step hopefully you can breed
for a superior variety again this goes
through multiple iterations
and maybe multiple experimental designs
to do this
but the end product should be of
breeding a superior candidate that has
that resistance the abiotic
or the biotic stress that you were
trying to solve in the first part
in step number one
then also aside from this which is i'm
going to put it just as an aside
having a genetic engineering project
that then can occur if you know what
metabolomic pathway
has a limitation and you can remove out
an enzyme involved knock out a gene
involved
those can help you make a superior
genetically superior plant that can
resist that biotic or abiotic stress
again that's
totally up to reference there still is
selective breeding
and then there's a genetic engineering
side so both sides are able to function
with this metabolomics pipeline
thank you very much for your attention
today and thank you again to lab roots
for hosting this talk
happy to answer any questions at this
time